see what else is happening oh I got the
hair that's what's been going on I'm
like what if I haven't been doing much I
got the hair rejuvenation again so you
know I love surgery and and I got it
so I've been having to chill that's been
the worst thing I've been having to
literally do nothing and then two days
ago I started getting sick so it's been
tough having you know they took it out
the back they took a decent crop and
they put it up in that front boy so here
in the back here in the front so but it
take a while they just take the seed now
a lot of people do not know this and
I've talked about it before on here but
if you do the fue hair surgery now I go
to this bit this fellow dr. kahan out
here in Beverly Hills fancy guy I'm not
sure where he from dude probably I don't
want to say maybe Middle East maybe
Antarctica I'm not sure dude but like
kind of darker Antarctica
you know ant dark touka you know he's
just I think you know he's uh he's a
Beverly Hills guy beautiful man
and he works and he worked in um in
transplanter a long before you know an
actual organ transplantation and now he
does hair so what they do they they
shave the back they take about maybe one
out of every 12 hairs out of the back or
30 hairs or something dig it out they
have a little bitty it's not like a
shovel but it's pretty much like a
little bit like a little you know
uncle baby billy shovel and they just I
mean they just run through the house
with a pickle in their mouth pulling
hairs out he is dumb how do you back
down back he ahead rear you know out of
that [ __ ] out of that big half dome
in the back how did that free solo
freaking back piece you know so they
pulled him out and then they dig a
little bitty holes in the front and they
have two nurses that come take the hairs
from the back put them in the front and
that's how it goes
took about four or five hours they give
you a valium so I started watching El
Camino and then I woke up like an hour
and a half later and I was in a watching
a soap opera song you know what the hell
happened but El Camino didn't seem that
good honestly but um so I did that did
that dirty trick were and uh and now
it's been recovering the hard part is
you can't do anything active so you
can't do gym you can't do yoga you have
to sleep at a 45 degree angle like a
shitty uh you know like a someone who's
supposed to do you know like that chubby
guy on the Nights Watch or whatever that
guy's name is el it's not Eldred but you
know I'm talking about the guy who's
taking care of somebody else's baby Smee
or what uh Smeagol not Smeagol
um but yeah you sleep at a 45 degree
angle you know like kind of like a
[ __ ] like a semi alert person I guess
like a somebody who sleepwalks but is
lazy said are not even doing it so
that's the tough part you got to stack
the pillows at a certain angle you got
to get the UM ruler or you can do a
thing on your phone now that shows you
what angles are so you got to get that
45-degree angle so I sleep at that
bastard and today was the first day I
could wash the back of the hair and just
pour a little water on the front and
that's been six or seven days five six
five six days so on Tuesday I'll be able
to resume I think some yoga and some
just moving around but it's such a book
because you get stagnant you get
stagnant and that's what hasn't been
good for me I don't like being stagnant
because when I'm not moving the things
around me I can be affected you know
this things can get me more the world
can get me more when I'm not moving and
so that's when you know I think for me
it's tough and that's when I get caught
thinking more about honestly more about
the dark arts because you're just right
there you know if a vulture is flying by
and they got a and they got a meat
that's sitting right there there's a
sitting meat then it's and they have one
meat that's rolling down the hill you
know a meat in motion then that birds
gonna get that sitting meat that SM and
that's what I feel like and that's why I
think it's just with this time of year
and this much you know energy in the air
it's like man I just want to get moving
again so I can you know get out of some
of these shadows and stuff and just make
sure I'll stay stay in the light brother
we're gonna be a part of the good stuff
huh so yeah I got the fue hair
transplantation it's my second time did
I need it probably not but you know I
don't spend money on much and I like
having hair you know I like having it
now one scary thing the flood the fum
the flow the they inject your scalp with
a bunch of different saline solution and
a bunch of stuff to numb the pain well
this junk starts at the second day and
third day you don't notice it but then
on the fourth day your forehead swells
up then the swelling rolls down your
face and you start to get swollen around
your eyes nose cheek if you're on the
YouTube I'll include some photos you
know cuz I like to be candid about it I
mean I look like a panther I look like a
white Panther I look like a kind of like
a somebody a fat snake that's kind of
dumb a little at one point I look like a
fire
a boy that had been maybe not in a fire
well maybe like a boy who'd been in like
a medium kind of fire and no disrespect
to anybody that's in a fire or has been
you know [ __ ] least you've been in the
fire bruh a lot of people afraid to even
[ __ ] step outdoors if things is
getting real he D and at least you've
been in the fire wow you know it's crazy
as my sister can't even read but what
does it have to do with us right now
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one